I've had several people come up to me and
say, “What can I do to be you?”
And the only aspect of me that’s really
doable is I can tell you what my academic
pedigree is and what I did as a kid and what
things interested me, but what I do day-to-day
is not the fulfillment of some preexisting
job description.
It’s just things that I took interest in
on my own that the general public happened
to also appreciate or like or want access
to.
And so within my job description as Director
of the Hayden Planetarium and as an educator,
as an astrophysicist, I kept accreting other
things that I did that people responded to,
positively responded to.
So, I can tell you about the academic pedigree.
The rest, you have to create what it is that
you do best that layers onto the formal training
that may be behind it.
I think the greatest of people that have ever
been in society, they were never versions
of someone else.
They were themselves.
You don’t think about Michael Jordan the
basketball player and say, “Oh, he was just
like this other player.”
No, you don’t even say, “He was like this
player plus that player divided by two plus
this.”
No.
He’s Michael Jordan.
I think the greatest of people in society
carved niches that represented the unique
expression of their combinations of talents,
and if everyone had the luxury of expressing
the unique combinations of talents in this
world, our society would be transformed overnight.
It’s the great tragedy -- people employed
in ways that don’t fully tap everything
they do best in life.
I am privileged and I don’t take a day for
granted on the job about the fact that what
I do, what people most warmly receive about
what I do, are some of the things that I do
best in life.
I'm honored and flattered by that combination
of facts as they apply to me.
So, your task is to find the combination of
facts that apply to you.
Then people will beat a path to your door.